what is going on everybody and welcome
to part 7 of the deep learning with
Python tensorflow in chaos tutorial
series in this part what we're going to
be talking about is the recurrent neural
network so the idea of a recurrent
neural network is that the order of some
data carries significance and importance
so two areas where this tends to be the
case is in like time series data where
data is organized temporally or
chronologically otherwise you might have
this is important in natural language so
the order of something in a sentence
carries a lot of importance as far as
the meaning of that sentence so for
example if you said you know some people
made a neural network what happens when
you feed it through some sort of natural
language processing algorithm let's say
that was just a deep neural network what
it usually tends to be the case is we're
gonna tokenize data which just means
let's say in this case we're gonna split
it by words so each word is its own
unique feature but the problem with a
deep neural network is this sentence
which have the same you know meaning as
a neural a neural network made some
people and obviously these two sentences
have widely varying meanings and impacts
and all that so it's important the order
of things in these sentences so so
that's the idea of a recurrent neural
network so how do they actually work and
I've got some beautiful beautiful
drawings I don't know who drew those but
man they're beautiful anyways so the
idea here is that let's say these green
boxes here these are recurrent cells so
you could have a basic recurrent cell
very rarely do these get used usually
it's like an LS TM which is short for
long short-term memory there's also the
gru or a gated recurrent unit but again
I just pretty much see everybody use LST
M cells in all honesty so the way these
work is you know you've got your
sequential data here and the sequential
data is passed in let's say to one of
these
and then the cell does - it outputs two
- two locations it outputs one to the
next layer but - and the next layer
could be the next you know it could be
input to the next recurrent type of
layer or it could be the output layer or
a dense layer who knows
but anyways each cell is gonna output
somewhere to another layer but also down
to the next node in the in the specific
recurrent layer now where are these
output - it doesn't necessarily have to
be - the next thing down and then it
also doesn't have to only go in one
direction you can have bi-directional
recurrent layers for example and you can
get really crazy with the with the order
of things and where data gets passed and
stuff but in general this is a super
basic one so a another way to look at it
is like this is one cell and so so let's
say you've got basically let's say this
is like the second one in the layer so
let's say it's like we're looking at
this cell right here so this green box
is this cell here okay so basically some
some data has come from the previous
cell it's wrapped around here it's
coming in and the lsdm cell that we're
looking at here it chooses okay what do
we want to forget from the previous node
then there's input data coming in okay
based on this input data what do we want
to add to this bundle of info that we've
got and then finally okay what based on
this bundle info what do we want to
output to both the next layer and the
next node that we want to output to so
that's the task of the LST M cell now
obviously that's pretty complicated
especially when you know all these
things like the whole point is to
eventually just pass along like a scalar
value so how do we do that very
challenging stuff if you want to learn
more about how LST M cells work
specifically there is a great timeless
right up on the LST M cell I linked to
it in the text-based version of the
tutorial so definitely go check that out
if you want to otherwise let's get into
writing our own basic
current neural network so what we're
gonna do in this video is just do a
really simple one just so we can get the
idea of like what really how easy a
recurrent neural network itself is but
they'll really the hard part with
recurrent neural networks is getting
your data set structured in such a way
because the type of data that you're
going to be using typically doesn't have
targets it has it's just time series
it's just informal kind of data and we
don't really have you know what are we
actually trying to point this to so
there's usually a huge amount of
pre-processing
involved in when you work with recurrent
neural networks so what we're gonna do
here is just use a simple M nest example
and in the next tutorial we'll do a
realistic example with some time series
data specifically with crypto currency
prices so yeah anyway I'm gonna minimize
this and let's begin with some imports
so import tensor flow as tea jerk always
does this to me if my tensor flow is TF
fix that then we're gonna go from tensor
tensor flow dot Karros models we're
going to import the sequential type of
model from tensor flow caras dot dot
layers we're going to import the dense
layer one because the output layer
itself needs to be a dense layer but
also we are gonna end with another like
a realistic you know a dense layer
before the output layer that's a pretty
common operation to do and then we're
gonna have some drop out just so nothing
gets overly weighted and the LST M cell
I am gonna comment here if you are on
the GPU version of tensorflow
check out the KU d NN l STM cell so even
if you are on the GPU version of
tensorflow this l esteem cell will
indeed run on your GPU but the KU d n NL
STM cell is even more optimized and i
it's like five plus times faster even
though both run on your GPU if you're on
the cpu version tensorflow well then you
know you're gonna this tutorial like to
this model is going to take like five
hours to train or something
either way okay so so those are the
things that we need and now we need the
data set so we're just gonna grab em
NIST real quick so M s is equal to TF
karosta datasets amnesty and then we
could just need to unpack it so it's
just these two tuples and then it's
extreme white rain then it's X test Y
test and that's M nest dot load
underscore data so again my apologies
for using M nests but I think it's
better to do it make this one it's basic
as possible and then in the next one
we're getting because honestly it would
take us it's probably like the next
one's probably gonna take us two three
maybe even four parts just to get to
okay now feed it through the neural
network and that's the easy part really
feeding it through is is not too hard so
so for example let's do let's just do a
print X train shape and then we should
be able to do to deduce this from the
above but X train and let's just get the
first sample dot shape just so we get
idea what we're dealing with here so so
we can see we've got 60,000 examples of
28 by 28 images and of course the
zeroeth element is just 28 by 28 so take
a minute pause and think about okay so
this is our training data and it's
already in sequences for us right and
what are the sequences well it's in
sequences like what is this 28 by 28
well its 28 rows of 28 pixels per row so
we could in theory say each each row is
a part of a sequence and if you were to
take the first row and then kind of scan
downwards could you figure out what the
number is probably so the so the hope is
that a recurrent neural network could
actually do this and maybe even more so
we should see that it it could plausibly
do it better than a deep neural network
but we'll see the more important thing
is just to show the recurrent net
anyways but yeah so that's the sequence
it's a sequence of rows of pixels that
were that we're going to be feeding
through this neural network so now we
want to build the actual model itself so
we're gonna say model equals I'm gonna
give us some space here model equals and
it's just gonna be that sequential type
of model now we're gonna do model that
ad and we're going to add in an LST M so
how many are at Ellis team layer right
how many cells do we want to have we're
just going to use 128 for now we're
gonna specify the input shape and that
is 28 by 28 we already kind of know that
but we can make this somewhat dynamic by
doing X train dot shape and then 1 : so
then we can pass an activation function
and we'll use our good friend rectified
linear and again do check out ku ku D
anomalous TM I'm just not going to do
that yet I'll probably change it before
we run it because it is really really
fast but for now we'll just keep it
whoops didn't mean to move that we'll
just keep it here okay so the next thing
that we want to do is one more parameter
which is return underscore sequences and
that's going to be true so do we want
this layer to return sequences like it
was input like sequences were input or
do we want this layer to return
something flat right so if we're going
to a dense layer we wouldn't want to
return sequences because the dense
layers not going to understand what the
heck's going on but if we're going to
another recurrent layer we definitely
want to return those sequences this is
just a long line anyway okay so so
that's one of our layers and then we're
just going to do model that ad and we'll
throw in a drop out because that's what
you do so we'll do a 20% drop out there
and then we'll do another layer so model
dot ad will add an LS TM where we'll do
another 120
eight we don't need to specify input
shape in fact I don't know why we never
have to and then we will pass an
activation function here activation
equals rectified linear we'll do a drop
out I'm just going to copy and paste
copy paste and then let's do a model dot
add will add a dense layer we'll make it
thirty two nodes and then activation
gosh can you guys think of what
activation oh yes that's right
rectified linear don't do a drop out and
then we'll do will go to the final dense
layer so I'm just gonna copy this paste
and I'm just gonna hard code in ten
that's just it's just how many classes
do you have so we're just gonna go with
ten the activation shouldn't be
rectified linear it should be soft max
at this point and okay I think we're
done there with like at least with our
you know model structure now all we need
to do is do the compile and then the
fitment so to do the compile we're gonna
have an optimizer compile compile
anyways TF Kara it's not optimizers
optimizers dot Adam and we'll just
specify a learning rate of 1e negative
three and then we'll do it two K well we
haven't really talked about two K but
we'll do it decay 1e negative six or
something probably that's too small
maybe one a negative five so a decay is
just over time we'd probably like you
want to start with a larger learning
rate to take those large steps that you
want to take and then but over time
you'll kind of find this like local spot
but probably your two if you took
smaller steps you could do even better
so if you keep taking those big steps
you're gonna keep bouncing around that
little u-shape but if you take a smaller
step you could plausibly do better so
anyways that's what decay is about it's
just over time every batch it's going to
decay the learning rate a little bit so
it's gonna keep shrinking that learning
rate and so you'll take smaller steps
anyways model dots
compile and we'll say loss equals sparse
categorical cross entropy I just want to
say they did add a shorthand for mean
squared error squared here you see you
know that's one way you can measure loss
and they said it was it's now you could
use MSE I'd really like it if they added
shorthand for all of them someone tell
me below if they have and I just don't
know about it but you know I'd like to
be able to say SCC that'd be nice I hate
typing that out okay so we've got our
loss the optimizer equals opt really
simple there and then the metrics that
we're gonna track here we'll just go
with accuracy and then finally model
that fit X train Y train epochs we'll do
three epochs validation data so we can
see it over time will be X test Y test
okay so that should be good to go
hopefully I can run this not crash the
computer cuz I know
sublime likes to really get me so we'll
go ahead and run that now I'll probably
just go through maybe one epoch up let's
see invalid syntax at the drop out what
did we and maybe not what line is that
14 did we not fully close this off we
didn't try again
but fruit okay things are looking good
so far alright and we are off we are
learning the accuracy does not look very
good but you can see how slow this is
like this is extremely slow I would
expect accuracy to be a little better
even by now I wonder why this is going
so painfully slow I wonder if I've made
a mistake even so I don't even see loss
going down and almost looks like loss is
going up 14 3 9 3 8
hmm
no first I saw this I was like oh that's
our problem no we've got our final dense
layer activation is soft mags what did
we screw up we have two screwed up
something it should be learning much
more by now so this isn't it oh I don't
know that we've ever showed this but I
brought it up at least what aren't we
doing here we are not normalizing this
data so we could use the chaos
normalization or we can just say X train
equals x train divided by 250 5x test
equals x test / 255 I'm gonna save that
the other thing I'm going to do while I
have you guys is show you
Couty and NL STM so let's go ahead and
import that as well I'm gonna change
this to KU tienen Alice TM and this one
and then you you can't the KU tienen
Dallas team uses a tan H activation
function which is you can google it if
you want to see like the shape of it but
you should be able to with rectified
linear you should still be able to get a
good accuracy here but the problem was
def I almost kind of I almost kind of
want to show you guys because I know
some people aren't gonna be able to run
this if they're on CPU and they just
want to learn so I guess I'll just rerun
it but we can even see so like this did
not train and hopefully that was the
problem gonna be really sad if that's
not the problem but the real almost
certainly the reason this didn't train
is because we didn't scale between 0 & 1
so let's see the example yeah I mean
look how much faster it's learning now
all we did was scale it between 0 & 1
that's how huge of an impact that makes
so yeah it's super important okay so I'm
gonna go ahead and break well I guess I
don't have to break it but I'm gonna
show you guys now kudi and n Alice TM
because it's so fast
you know it's paste paste and then I'm
gonna delete this and deLee this whoops
we do want to have that
so see we're already out like 4140 I'm
sure we're gonna get into like the 90s
or something but let me eta to three
minutes so now let's run this one
hopefully I'm not gonna crash the GPU
sublime is pretty bad
I probably should be running this in a
console instead but whatever look at
this I got fast this is the best the
best thing ever
what a great little addition
I mean recurrent Nets are so slow this
kudi and NL is TM sell is just glorious
so we're already at an accuracy of you
know 96% and before epochs were taking I
don't know we were pretty deep into that
one and it was like 2 minutes and 30
seconds to go
whereas these entire epochs are taking
13 seconds that's that's crazy okay so I
think we're only gonna run for three
epochs so I guess I'll just let this one
finish good done so validation so
accuracy here 97 0.73 validation
actually did better ninety-eight point
11 I don't know if I can get back to the
other layers or not I did want to show
like on this so like on something like
this I think the reason why validation
accuracy is higher than accuracy is
because this is an average for the
entire epoch whereas this is like at the
end of the epoch we run it so and that's
also why like this is that the this is
an average for the epoch so then after
the next epoch we can see a lot of times
our average will jump quite a bit but
even in this case it's still low lower
than the validation accuracy which tells
me we actually probably could have
continued to train because by the end of
the epoch we were much much better but
we can also look at intense our board is
lost still falling and all that so
anyways that is all for now in the next
tutorial we will go over a far more
complex example of doing this on like a
realistic time series data set because
that it just takes so much more work but
I didn't want to bog us down with the
pre-processing without this because
actually you know fee
through a recurrent net itself as long
as you have data that's already is in
sequential form and already has a target
it's actually pretty simple so anyways
that's it for now a quick shout out to
the most recent channel members Taj
Jagdish Dana Larsen and Julio no sorry
if I mispronounced anybody's names here
it's pretty crazy how many like people's
like different names that I've never
heard before and I have no idea how to
pronounce so I'm really sorry but it's
just crazy like my audience just comes
from from everywhere so it's really cool
to see and again thank you guys so much
for your support it's really appreciated
so anyway that's all for now if you have
questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below if I did
screw something up in general there's a
red flag if validation accuracy is
higher than accuracy but I do believe my
explanation before is why that's the
case
also I'm I'm very confident that their
data is prepared correctly but anyways
if that ever does happen to you that
should always be a massive red flag keep
training and make sure that that is not
the case off forever anyways that's it
for now questions comments concerns
whatever feel free to leave below if
you've got any requests for things that
you'd like to see in this series let me
know otherwise I will see you guys in
another video